Speaker 1: The David Pakman show continues
to be a community funded program.
You can support the work.
We do so many different ways, but the best
way, the most powerful way, the most direct
way continues to be to sign up it, join Packman
dot com and get yourself a membership.
Not only will you get access to the Daily
Bonus show and the commercial free audio and
video streams of the show and you'll get the
show hours before everybody else and you'll
get invited to the member town halls.
We are also soon to launch a member soundboard
where you will have access to my soundboard
clips.
Speaker 2: Now all the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: You will get access to the soundboard.
Okay, Very, very cool stuff going on.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com.
Let's hear from people in the audience.
We are going to take some calls because it
is after all Friday we do this via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's go to west Wesley from Nashville.
Wesley, welcome to the program.
What is on your mind today, my friend?
Speaker 2: David, can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Hi.
So I was just wondering where you would currently
assess our chances of the United States defaulting
on its national debt if the Republicans fail
and the Freedom Caucus is able to hold Congress
hostage enough and Congress fails to raise
the debt ceiling?
Speaker 1: Extremely low.
I would not bet that the U.S. is going to
default on its debt.
I believe that Republicans are more than willing
to damage the country by holding out on the
debt ceiling debate.
I believe ultimately the same thing that always
happens is going to happen.
The U.S. will not default on its debt and
even the Freedom Caucus crazies are not going
to ultimately make that happen.
Speaker 2: Interesting.
I guess I was just wondering because I was
reading something on The New York Times this
morning regarding a couple discussions about
the last major debt ceiling fight.
Yes.
And how the Democrats and Republicans kind
of had two different takeaways as a result.
And I just worry when I look at, you know,
the Chip Roy's in the Mac gates as if they
even really understand the implications of
the brinkmanship they're practicing and what
would actually occur if the United States
was to default.
I think that makes I wonder if that makes
the risk so much significantly higher than
very typically would assume it would be.
Speaker 1: Well, they don't understand it.
But here's the thing.
Even if they did, they wouldn't really care.
So it's one of those things where you're completely
right.
They don't actually understand it.
But I also don't believe that they would dramatically
change their views if all of a sudden you
explained it to them.
These these people have a completely different
moral compass and framework than we do.
And I just don't think they care.
Speaker 2: I fully, fully agree.
Thank you for taking my call.
Big fan.
Been a big watcher for years and years.
First time caller.
Obviously I'm a bit nervous, but hopefully
this was a satisfactory call for you and your
show today.
Speaker 1: More so that more more than satisfactory.
Wesley, I appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
All right.
Speaker 1: There we go.
Wesley from Nashville with some very important
statements and questions.